alors on va voir un deuxième extrait
parce que c'est vrai qu on va un extrait
de laëtitia qui était hier dans
l'émission quotidien et son passage a
fait pas mal réagir hier soir certains
le trouvaient de langue de bois d'autres
n'ont pas trouvé sincère le ont reproché
de continuer à rendre hommage à johnny
dans un but financier
florian cynique il va nous dire ce
qu'ils en pensent renault 6 1 voilà et
on commence avec cet extrait où elle
évoque sa relation avec david et laura
donc les enfants de johnny et regarder
les t-shirts et l'ex tout le monde à
respirer la présence de david hallyday
de laura smet et puis finalement non on
en aurait on aurait rêvé ouais on les a
invités j'aurais rêvé que david puis-je
sont et 100% ce soir là je les propose
et j'ai j'ai lancé des invitations vous
êtes parlé ils voulaient dont ce pas là
avec les airs en travers les avocats
mais c'est dommage seulement 13 avocats
mais je je je continue à espérer que
l'on y arriverait un jour je vais
essayer de peut les appeler oui oui on
j'ai envoyé des messages
mais voilà c'est il faut ils sont pas
les associés à l'hommage du tout on l'a
on est on leur a proposé on les a
invités et je refusais ils ont fusé
enfin ils ont fait savoir qu'ils
pourraient pas être là
alors florian merci d'être là vous êtes
expert en communication politique
normalement mais vous intéressait aussi
à laetitia parce que tout le monde s'y
intéresse un johnny laeticia on voit la
jolie et 0 stéphane absolue de johnny et
c'est vrai que laëtitia y en a qui l'on
reproché d'avoir été un petit peu langue
de bois ce que vous la trouvez sincère
là tu es ce que vous comprenez sa
stratégie de communication mais bon elle
a évidemment été préparé par des
communicants à cet exercice jorion
préparer mon équipe ma part comme ça
avec rien n'est naturel ici tout est
préparé et la difficulté des exercices
c'est que ça se retourne contre elle ça
ne la sert pas de faire ce genre
d'interview d'abord parce que dans le
même temps elle a donné plusieurs
interviews pour expliquer à quel point
les deux filles étaient devenus des
étrangers pour david et laurent gerra
des 17 exactement cette façon de
diaboliser les héritiers de johnny ça
pose une difficulté quand le message
principal qu'elle vient délivrer chez
quotidien c'est je veux l'apaisement et
je veux être l'élément de réconciliation
familiale il ya une contradiction qui
est insurmontable qu'elle incarne à ses
dépens et c'est ce qui est aujourd'hui
critiqué ce qui lui est reproché
c'est d'autant plus dommage j'en termine
la queue elle a quelque chose
d'insurmontable aujourd'hui
qu'il faut résoudre avec une
communication et qu'elle sait pas
surmonter c'est que l à cliver il y a
maintenant dans le public de johnny les
antilles l'éthicien et pro laetitia sa
communication elle devrait d'abord être
avoir comme objectif le fait de
rassembler ces deux camps qui sont trop
serrées cas les antilles les voilà bien
sûr mais en même temps elle est pris
dans un étau ingérable elle est
finalement pris entre sa vie privée la
carrière de johnny je pense qu'elle
aurait dû effectivement aller uniquement
sur la carrière de johnny parce qu'elles
se retrouvent piégés dans une commune
communication qui est non maîtrisée elle
peut pas maîtriser cette situation c'est
ingérable
alors où on ya un deuxième extrait elle
évoque la relation entre johnny et jean
paul belmondo qui nous a quittés la
semaine dernière après avoir parlé de
leur amitié hors du commun elle a fait
un petit commentaire sur l'hommage
national de jean paul belmondo qui n'est
pas passé inaperçu on regarde
belmondo avait eu droit à un hommage
national pour donner vous avez préféré
l'hommage populaire quelque chose de
moins institutionnel et de moins
protocolaire pourquoi parce que c'est ce
qu'ils voulaient gg j'ai suivi un
ses volontés je n'aurais pas aimé d'un
hommage national trop solennel désaveu
yves c'est sa vie c'était le plus le
public populaire et
c'était un cri d'amour pour jean-paul au
6 mai mais l'hommage national aurait été
trop liste peut-être pour lisser sens et
j'ai trouvé les hommages de jean paul
belmondo magnifique et j'étais
bouleversé la la fin ça m'a versé
beaucoup de larmes et 1 mais pour johnny
way la descente des champs-elysées puis
après les choses se sont faites
naturellement oui ça s'il ya une petite
polémique le plus gros preuve c'est
qu'elle me l'autre comme miss france
tanning donc tu sais jamais été très
bien là
c'était très très beau s'est dit tu sais
jamais si c'est sincère passagers sans
laquelle les sens sont pas méchants on
n'en sait rien on écoute une poupée de
communication cayla qui minaude et je
sais plus courants penser c'est sous
elle est vraiment sincère quand elle dit
par exemple je vais présenter mon
nouveau maître sur la tonne alors
justement regarder ça alors vous verrez
qu'elle a présenté jalil lespert pleine
bourre mais le réalisateur elle a
présenté à la combe de johnny
ça c'est pas de la com
c'est une femme qui a toujours été comme
ça avec johnny et beaucoup d'amour entre
eux ils ont apporté beaucoup de choses
maginnis isabelle morini-bosc présenter
tous ses ex sélection padres a dit au
père lachaise
autres compagnons j'avais je l'espère à
johnny sur la tombe de johnny à
saint-barth ouais c'est un jeu une étape
importante pour moi
je retrouve goût à l'existence grâce à
adja libre
son amour me porte tous les jours me
transporte et je suis persuadé que c'est
tony qui me renvoie
pour réapprendre à vivre et à aimer et
c'est une belle rencontre c'est un
quelqu'un qui compte énormément pour moi
c'était important de le présenter à
johnny
avait toujours parler les morts il
aurait beaucoup aimé que je passe un
très beau couple ému que j'ai beaucoup
aimé
coupé mais elle fait parler le morte
voit vraiment qu'il aurait beaucoup aimé
qui lui présente sur notre
sol ou alors je loue moi je pense que
c'est à la fois un manque d'élégance de
respect mais surtout cette mise en scène
avait quelque chose d' extrêmement
choquante à quel moment un conseiller en
communication a pu lui suggérer de dire
sur deux choses donc où elle a fait
cette interview chez quotidien pour
gêner les bourses en rien mes roses et
peut-être sincère télécom a juste je lui
souhaite d'être sincère je serai de ne
pas avoir préparé son charme des tous
savent très bien que va penser le fan de
johnny lorsqu'il entend fonds
instrumentaliste son nom alors qu'il est
décédé dans une relation qui apparaît
déjà comme une trahison alors que
l'image qu'elle traîne dans le pinot
française c'est celle d'être une veuve
nous et tu sais ce que disait richelieu
la trahison c'est une question de date
sa fin on embrasse d'ailleurs je compte
nous regarde
jérôme et issia quoi qu'elle fasse mais
oui quoi qu'elle fasse tout le monde lui
tombe dessus
unique en télé pas laquelle vit sa vie
elle manque de relais anthony laissez la
tranquille ou non
grid en même temps là le droit d'avoir
une vie privée mais bien sûr mais bon
c'est el paso ses activités par celle de
choc qui l'attendait juge de la mise en
scène et de sa relation avec ce qu'elle
avec johnny martin qui peut pas tuer
pourquoi il est d'accord ou pas il
devrait garder son goût elle n'a même
pas justifié cette relation
laura et david c'est ça qu'on peut
vraiment lui reprocher parce que le mot
mais on est jeune c'est son interview
d'un quotidien aussi
je distille jeux pc non mais même
l'avocate alice à marthe cents à nous
pour gianni sauf que les précédents
la principale a dit ou pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce que nie le précédent 620
2010 le restaurateur vrai le kit parce
que johnny ne comprendrait pas que je
vive un amour
elle commence avec jalil est jeune
elle avait vu entre deux tombes à
laquelle il faut faire un choix où elle
vit sa vie ce qui est normal parce que
votre compère son mari ou ailleurs ça
les jeunes très bien elle trouva un
affluent sur bison on aime beaucoup mais
je la dalle est soit avec le fiancé elle
communique sur twitter son machin astana
alejos n'y a pas de problème soit elle
parle de johnny et le mélange des deux
essais d'halfpenny oui c'est pour ça que
les fans sont son son père lui pas fait
ou l'un ou l'autre allez tu peux pas
faire une croix sur ma
maison mes soucis dit tu veux pas dire
je n'y aurais adoré mon mec c'est pas
possible
la cisa
moi je le trouve très très donneurs de
leçons et c'est d'accord avec guillaume
elle était une mariée suspecte elle et
une vf si
amoureuse suspecte mais oui on peut
semer ouais mais surtout que la plupart
des morts sont à peu près d'accord avec
ce que l'on demande de dire et richelieu
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mixer dans sa chambre à coucher on sait
pas alors bien sûr mais d'un choix alors
une autre séquence il ya la séquence
émotion à la plus réussie de rallye
tossiat alors elle a pleuré en regardant
des images de johnny et ses filles
regardait n'a pas pu retenir ses larmes
même si mike brand qui avait demandé à
l'époque le jockey davy crockett qui
n'a jamais peur
leur père elle est une mythologie
française comment elle gère sa
basse et leur papa ok devons toujours
vécu elles le voient comme leur papa
qu'est ce que ce qui était une
formidable dans le jade et joy sont des
petites filles adoptées qui ont vécu
l'abandon comme johnny et johnnie
il a réussi à pardonner à son père quand
il a quand il a adoptées jade et joy l'a
avancé dans sa vie différemment en étant
un père différent beaucoup plus présent
du coup cluzel écoute elle a fait
l'amour dans le pré acheté ou plaise ou
non mais non mais non c'est elle et
quand c'est la vérité elle est comme ça
allait dans sa vie tout ça allait mais
les quinze jours nous mettra
25 25 22 oui c'est vrai non mais voilà
vous vous avez mis à la recette unitaire
garder ou non je regarde pas parce que
ça ne m'intéresse pas en fait c'est pas
salé c'est la vie c'est parce que vous
n'aimez pas davy crockett mais j'aimais
c'est d'essayer des trucs que tu en
étais fan de johnny comme moi j'étais
fan de johnny à la mairie les cégeps
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'étais très fan de johnny je trouve que
le fait qu'elle vienne à la télé comme
ça à s'exposer elle se met en différé le
droit là pour moi je préférerais qu'elle
reste de côté qui a mis son histoire
avec jeanine 30 manon aux études quand
tu commences à comparer les deux
regardez ce qui s'est vu avec jean paul
belmondo vous avez vu la classe-c ma
classe de la famille et regarder ce qui
est triste c'est que eux ils se
déchirent elle dit carrément on se parle
avec avocat par un veau cas opposé tu
peux pas comparer mais moi je pense
qu'il qui se passe à devra rester ou
aller sous les projecteurs et celle qui
demande à aller chez quotidien et à ce
moment là elle accepte les critiques
derrière elles avaient toutes un plan de
com mais elles n'ont pas de place avec
des sections ça existe
encore au temps non pas du tout méritée
il ya des chemins ce qu'on appelait
alors parce qu'on a fait et j'en ai
besoin d'un concert palais des gens voir
chanter johnny b
elle est vraiment un [ __ ] mais c'est
quoi ce soit jean macé qui pour des
beaucoup de chauffeurs parti ce matin
concernant me confirmait à moi allions y
avait des niçois sa bande à bercy il
sait rien vendu du tout ce soir un
concert en direct sur france2 mur lancé
par michel drucker et le drame il part
de l'asse pour sa faute de main
[Rires]
alors moi je ne mange pas de cul non
donc ce soir si le couple ne rebondissez
pas je vais essayer c'est donc ce soit
il reste plein de place ils ont entendu
qu à peine 2000 il y avait dix mille
places en vente ses 2004 a transmis bah
oui c'est une cata téva lui vendu
je suis avec la vie qu'avec un seul ont
fait derrière mais c'est
sa soupe et enfin les
investisseurs à la faillite parce
qu'elle a fini par se confier sur ces
quatre dernières années qui ont été très
dures selon elle la pauvre laetitia
entre le décès de johnny les nombreuses
trahisons mais elle a voulu malgré tout
laissé un message positif regarder avec
laeticia je positive attitude faite le 4
on a vécu énormément d'abandon nos
trahisons de déception mais c'est je
partage cette
c'est ses douleurs de la vie c'est que
la vie nous a imposé ses il faut essayer
d'avancer avec résilience et puis
pardonner et puis dire merci aux gens
qui nous ont abandonnés qui ont été qui
sont comportés de manière tellement
décevante avec monkey leur dire merci
parce que ça nous fait grandir ça nous
apprend aussi sur l'être humain sur les
valeurs humaines et je crois que c'est
un cadeau aussi peut être pour elle
d'apprendre ça fait trop mal vu moi je
trouverais lancé mme au métro elle sait
pas faire elle est mal à l'aise par
rapport à oui il faut pas lui en vouloir
dans votre commune et ou trois concerts
plein causé par son rôle est là qu à
vivre son histoire d'amour avec jalil
qui manquent de rien ils ont tous ils
sont ils ont tous ils sont impatients de
les aider mais ils ont tout ce qu'ils
veulent dans la vie dont tous et trois
conseillers s'est du coup elle ne sait
pas comment ses conseillers que vous mal
à la corde en tout cas merci
[Rires]